oui
bien sûr suis-je le seul est-ce qu'on se
pose la question non demain quoi qu'il
se passe il n'y aura pas d'abrogation de
la réforme des retraites notre phrase du
jour est signée Yaël brune Pivet la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
directe elle annonce qu'elle fera
barrage à l'examen de la mesure
d'abrogation de la retraite à 64 ans
présentée par le groupe liotte en
réponse la France insoumise a annoncer
qu'elle déposerait une motion de censure
contre le gouvernement ils vont
peut-être commencer à bosser ces
opposants et passe à autre chose parce
que foot le bordel ça demande comme
beaucoup de temps et d'énergie donc
champion du monde des grèves la honte la
honte restaurant fermée les commerces
qui bossent pas les touristes qui
veulent punir parce que on crame tout
parce qu'il y a les gilets jaunes
en fait ça fait des années que le pari
ça commence à descendre dans les villes
les plus bas c'est bien on va devenir
les clochards de l'Europe le Tiers Monde
de l'Europe non mais c'est bon en plus
c'est quand tu regardes dans les détails
et c'est pas une réforme brutale
violente ça aurait pu être pire bon
voilà c'est 64 ans on va pas mourir faut
arrêter on se demandait
la Communauté française elle est
importante en Allemagne
et bien hier dans le ciel Rennais un
drone de la police a donc été pris pour
cible non pas par des manifestants mais
par des opposants inattendus des oiseaux
de mer la séquence a fait beaucoup rire
au cœur du défilé des mouettes ou des
goélands selon les témoins se sont
attaqués au drone piloté par les
policiers la scène a même été filmée par
des manifestants et du côté de La
Courneuve on souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire à ce mec qui est très bien
entouré en tout cas super
alors au final le drone n'a pas été
endommagé pas d'oiseaux blessés non plus
aux dernières nouvelles mais concernant
le phénomène ce n'est pas surprenant
d'après la ligue de protection des
oiseaux qui étaient interrogés par nos
confrères du télégram ils expliquent
qu'on est en période de nidification
pour les goélands et que pour protéger
leur petit et bien il s'en prennent à
tout ce qui pourrait constituer une
menace y compris donc un drone qui
s'incruste comme ça dans leur espace
aérien
[Applaudissements]
c'est important Erasmus en Allemagne
[Musique]
Erasmus cartonne
les journalistes ont voulu savoir s'il
avait recadré Élisabeth borne suite à
ses propos sur le RN héritier de Pétain
et alors là le chef de l'État il nous a
répondu un truc de l'espace on écoute
vous me dites si vous comprenez quelque
chose concentrez-vous ce qu'on a voulu
créer avec la première ministre n'est
même pas de la littérature mais du
clapotis mais il a aussi il faut de la
rigueur parce que sinon on crée en
quelque sorte des bulles de savon et il
y a même plus de mousse ce qui s'est
passé alors
manger des fleurs
[Musique]
j'ai mon président qui déconne il fait
un bruit bizarre écouter et même plus de
mousse
[Musique]
carburant à quoi bah je sais pas mais
c'est de la bonne ça lui arrive souvent
de vous dire un truc qui a aucun sens
ni sur un patrimoine qui leur
permettrait d'avoir des revenus annexes
pardon
sauf qu'en dessous en effet il y a des
gens
et il y a des gens qui sont mouillés
travaillons avec devant ce lycée du
centre-ville de Marseille elles sont ce
matin une dizaine apportée labaya cette
robe longue et ample traditionnelle au
Moyen-Orient et populaire parmi ces
lycéens moi j'aime beaucoup c'est très
élégant je trouve il y a des femmes qui
n'aiment pas forcément montrer leur
corps du coup c'est une tenue qu'en plus
qui est belle c'est lycée de les enlever
avant d'aller en cours car la direction
de l'établissement a interdit les abayas
au même titre que les voiles sur 30 on
doit être
sur 30 élèves à apporter des à Bayards
juridique est aujourd'hui tolérée dans
les établissements scolaires le
gouvernement est plusieurs personnalités
politiques se montrent aujourd'hui de
plus en plus préoccupé par la situation
donc la laïcité on la défend partout et
on la défend notamment à l'école alors
faut-il interdire la tenue
traditionnelle de la Baya
tu sais que ça va être la brigade qui va
se battre pour nous donc voilà trop
content de les voir trop content de les
voir en plus ils sont beaux comme ça
tout en noir là
c'est la classe à Dallas une société
multiculturelle à vieux jours la Baya
montre cette nouvelle France qui a une
autre histoire qui a d'autres codes qui
ne prient pas le même Dieu qui envisage
peut-être la vie d'une façon différente
l'histoire rapporte que les sociétés
multiculturelles sont aussi
conflictuelles comment nous notre
tradition universaliste sera-t-elle
compatible ces prochaines années avec
ses différences communautaires voilà une
question clé pour les 67 millions de
Français que nous sommes le
rassemblement national vous vous accuse
de faire du copier-coller low cost ils
disent que c'est la version wish de leur
programme vous savez ce que c'est que la
version wish
vous savez ce que c'est
bon
le seul pays d'Europe où il y a une loi
de cette nature
on peut pas dire qu'on ne fait rien
[Musique]
je peux
je suis désolé j'ai pris mon tour de
parole
la direction du magasin lui reproche de
chanter trop fort plus capsurde pour
trois syndicats du magasin et mon avis
de lumière parce que je trouve ça
inadmissible qu'on puisse sanctionner à
nos collègues pour avoir chanté quoi
voilà ce n'est qu'une chanson même si
elle est entre guillemets un peu faute
de temps en temps la France est un pays
où l'on chantait les gens chantaient
et on chantait un maçon
si on chantait la la la la la moi
selon une récente enquête trois Français
sur 10 adaptés eux-mêmes la dose ou la
durée des médicaments prescrits un sur
cinq à surprendre des doses plus fortes
tandis qu'un sur deux dix donnait des
médicaments à ses proches présentant des
symptômes similaires enfin une personne
sur trois considère peu risqué le fait
de prendre des pilules périmées un
comportement qui peut avoir de graves
conséquences
se faire sanctionner pour avoir chanté
sa bonne humeur dans un magasin qui est
fermé au client de 4 heures à 8h30 du
matin mais c'est le monde à l'envers il
chantait
c'est ça fait partie de l'ambiance du
magasin tout le monde le fait un peu
dans tous les dans tous les périmètres
lui il faisait chez nous en rayon cave
donc
effectivement il y a un petit il y a une
petite suspicion
pardonnez-moi je souris j'ai évidemment
je je dis ça au second degré évidemment